what's happening there reject nation 45
years in the making we have ourselves a
trailer for avatar 2. if you caught our
youtube short we did not watch the trailer
in the theaters intentionally here we
are today if you guys can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated
let's see what all the glory is
and we're back
wow good to see you good day
jake sully
wow
nipple chills chills
damn humans
wow wow
i know one thing wherever we go
this family
wow
here's our fortress damn that [__] it so
much better yeah and did they let him have
his australian accent i don't think so it's not
like his actual voice i guess so yeah because
i've watched this again recently the the first
one on an oled tv on like 4k and then so it was
noticing like yeah the visual effects still look
great but there are some shading things that they
could definitely do just looking back at this now
i'm like oh yeah they they fix a lot oh my god the
engine's so sunny like whatever they used you had
to control the light and the physics in this is
is absolutely gorgeous and that's something that
i remember from the original film and especially
in 3d that's something that got me excited to see
that even just water is is present in the title of
the movie because one of the things that worked so
well about this the transport of experience of the
3d in that first movie was in sequences where
water was heavily prominent or glass or both i
rarely get excited for a 3d movie but this is one
where i'm like i gotta see that on the biggest and
most deep screen possible well i think they shot
this with imax cameras here's how we witnessed
it i took four seconds of footage where we had
to wait only got a little bit of a recording
there way in the hallway that's the only way we
saw 1 20th of the screen for like five seconds
let's just wait a minute then right back in
here yeah i heard this movie took forever
to get made especially because of the fact that
they are dealing so much with being underwater
and that was one of the biggest challenges of can
they really handle the mocap underneath there and
they figured out a way to do it apparently this
doesn't really give you a lot of insight into the
trailer from my understanding that this is going
to be a bit of a time jump where jake and nathiri
they have children now they have like a whole
family like three of them and they really neglect
the first one very emotionally abusive to that one
but baby gets all the attention the middle child
is like observing what's going on it's real family
comedy in the middle that's what i'm gonna be
dealing with uh them and then they're like i think
they're looking for a new home because apparently
something happened in the last movie to their
other oh no industrialization when will it end
these sons i thought they got rid of them at the
end but apparently they're back you know the human
uh uh spirit will never stop from trying to obtain
unobtainium so i feel like yeah maybe there's been
like a second wave of people trying to come and
mine and colonize or yeah maybe there's some
kind of other circumstance but either way clearly
we're gonna be dealing with the same two worlds
colliding here and nobody knows how yet but james
cameron's talked about like you know we're going
to bring steven lang back so i feel like that
whole organization is probably going to persist
through these four movies or whatever is planned
well it is still called avatar and it's easy to
forget that the avatar is some type of human
navi gene splice thing that was created so i
wonder what the development of the actual avatar
itself is did they do something where they were
able to get stephen lang and upload him into an
avatar himself you know steven blue steven ling i
love it make him blind crossover yeah you have him
and courtney weaver's supposed to return and james
cameron said that her character would be returning
but then sigourney weaver came out and that she's
playing like a different character she's still
gonna have that assertive sigourney weaver
classic personality you know that's what i love
about her so it seems like a woman i would never
want to piss off yeah yeah but like all the other
women i gladly pissed them off any day of the week
she'll take that respect
yeah so she's going to be returning and you saw
this character featured prominently in the trailer
more than our returning characters i don't know
jake champions who's the actor the actor playing
this person yeah who's like born on the can on
the settlements on pandora or whatever i thought
he would be fine then like if he's body adjusted
they show him with the oxygen mask that they have
he's like the george of the jungle of this that's
right yeah yeah he's gonna be the new white savior
to unite the worlds together i mean the last movie
already had you know like let's face it the navi
very much inspired by native american and african
culture and then white man steps in culturally
appropriates and becomes our savior that's right
yeah that's what we do that's why history loves us
yeah it's good stuff dude it's good this guy
you know this other guy born of the humans
but he prefers to spend time with the navi well
i'm excited to see the the reef people i'm not
even going to attempt to pronounce their name
with an m um meticulous or something of metals
i think what the the biggest showcase of this
trailer had to evoke are the visuals gonna look
better because that was one of the biggest things
about the first movie well people would often sort
of pan the story which on my second w i had only
watched it again for the first time a week ago
i actually really enjoyed a lot and the the
story may not be the strongest part of it and the
biggest part of it is often you know the wonder
the world the aura of pandora oh oh bars in the
cars at the stars i love seeing you know like yeah
the showing off the development of the technology
that was already so groundbreaking and now we'll
see here they're gonna do the high frame rate
thing that peter jackson did with hobbit but good
i'm curious very curious to see because that's
the other impressive thing is is james cameron
seems to find i don't know if he specifically
looks for stories that force him to innovate but
yeah like i'm really curious to see how that plays
this time around as well as alongside the other
innovations they had to do to shoot underwater
my favorite aspect of the original avatar was
just that aura and that sort of beautiful tribal
spirit that really permeates the whole tone that
you can appropriate that i appreciate more than
most people and i love they need their day in
the sun so let me step in and give it to them
i'm gonna your culture is great i think i can
figure out what we can really do to make this
shine right come with me let me dress up like you
this is really taking me back to that feeling of
just wonder and transportation and just this
beautiful tribal like while there is struggle
and everything like that just this looked like the
greatest video game sim i want to get into vr for
well it's funny looking at the last avatar movie
it looks like a great ps5 video game and which is
like a great cinematics off of a video game this
looked like a movie yeah which in 15 years it'll
look like a great ps7 video yeah well you're like
wow the rendering on siri's face man it looks real
but yeah i'm excited for it i can't wait to see
it all right guys what did you think leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe click that
bell leave a like and we'll catch you guys soon